[Música]
[Aplausos]
hace algunas semanas mis hijos me
hicieron una pregunta que seguramente a
ustedes también alguien en algún momento
les ha hecho la pregunta era qué
superpoder te gustaría tener no recuerdo
qué fue lo que contesté pero sí recuerdo
que durante algún tiempo le estuve dando
vuelta a la idea ustedes piensen lo que
les gustaría poder hacer y un día cuando
estaba sentado en un parque llegué a una
respuesta me gustaría poder volar
y en ese momento un águila se posó sobre
mi brazo
aún tengo las marcas no es cierto pero
fijamos que eso pasó
las aves ya podían volar a mí me
gustaría pero las aves lo pueden hacer
entonces pensé sería muy bueno también
poder respirar bajo el agua los peces lo
pueden hacer
y algún otro que tal tener visión
nocturna
la serpiente lo pueden hacer entonces
poder vivir 500 años o más
los árboles base si se puede decir que
lo hacen
entonces ser del tamaño de una hormiga
quien es del tamaño de hormiga
por las hormigas bueno cada uno que se
me ocurría resultaba que alguien en la
naturaleza ya lo podía hacer volar o
cualquiera de estas otras cosas parecía
que lo que estaba ocurriendo era que la
evolución había dado de alguna manera a
lo largo de cientos miles o millones de
años superpoderes a cada uno de los
seres vivos superpoderes que le servían
muy bien a cada uno en su contexto
piensen en un momento cómo funciona la
evolución la evolución es un proceso
sumamente complejo y muy lento sobre
todo para las criaturas que son de
nuestra talla en los seres vivos
pequeños esto puede funcionar mucho más
rápido pero nuestro nivel esto puede
parecer muy lento y por eso a veces
parece como que no hay cambios como
ocurre en estos cambios pues resulta que
por la manera en que nos reproducimos
siempre hay variación en qué consiste
esto ustedes se parecen a sus padres no
son iguales pero se parecen sus padres
separan
a sus padres un poco sí pero esto va
variando entonces siempre hay cosas en
las cuales nos parecemos y algunas otras
en los cuales somos un poco diferentes
esta variación como se da o cuáles
rasgos de los que tenemos podríamos
heredar después o cuáles desaparecerán
bueno piensen en dos principios uno
sería se pueden conservar o se suelen
conservar los rasgos que representan
alguna especie de ventaja reproductiva
es decir que nos permitirán dejar más
descendencia pero también se conservan
los rasgos que aunque no representen una
ventaja tampoco representan alguna
desventaja que ejemplo podemos poner
pues caminar
caminar y él nos dejaba las manos libres
para hacer otras cosas entonces ese es
un rasgo que se puede conservar en las
siguientes generaciones uno que tal vez
les parezca un poco extraño alguien me
lo preguntara qué pasa por ejemplo con
el apéndice tenemos apéndice y el
apéndice pues no representa
aparentemente una ventaja reproductiva
alguien me dijo el otro día bueno en
algunos lugares ya se han registrado
casos en los cuales la gente nace hay
casos en los que la gente nace sin
apéndice esto quiere decir que a la
larga dejaremos de tener apéndice no lo
creo por la siguiente razón él si puede
ver nacer a alguien sin apéndice bueno
hay gente que nace sin muchas cosas pero
resulta que nacer sin apéndice no
representa una ventaja reproductiva al
menos podría representarla pero en un
escenario que sería un poco extraño cómo
sería que repentinamente por ejemplo las
mujeres empezarán a sentirse atraídas
por los hombres que no tienen apéndice
es decir que los vieran y dijeran mira
y dicen que no tiene apéndice
esto no va a pasar
entonces tenemos apéndice para muchos
años sí bueno entonces cuando estaba
pensando en estas cosas se me ocurrieron
como ustedes seguramente ya se les
ocurrieron algunos poderes que podrían
ser interesantes y les voy a hablar de
31 podría ser tener una memoria
fotográfica es decir recordar todo
perfectamente otro podría ser que tal si
pudiera cerrar los oídos como cierro los
ojos para aislarme del mundo y otro mi
preferido que tal poder predecir el
futuro
hablemos del primero una memoria
fotográfica cómo funciona nuestra
memoria nuestra memoria funciona de
manera conjunta con otros procesos por
ejemplo la tensión y la emoción es decir
recordamos aquellas cosas a las cuales
les prestamos atención y recordamos
aquellas cosas que son importantes y
pueden ser importantes por dos razones
una porque son placenteras o porque son
displacenteras recordamos lo que es
importante lo que queda por ahí en medio
lo que es más o menos gris no lo
recordamos como sería recordar todo eso
pues nuestra memoria estaría abrumada
abrumada de información y de neo funes
el personaje de borges tenía tan buena
memoria que cuando quería recordar un
día de su vida tardaba un día completo
en recordarlo porque recordaba todos y
cada uno de los momentos de ese día
pero no necesitamos a la ficción
alexander nuria un psicólogo soviético
en el siglo pasado tuvo un paciente muy
curioso tan curioso que escribió un
libro sobre él y lo que ocurría con este
paciente es que tenía unas quejas sobre
su memoria pero no como las nuestras
él se quejaba de que no podía olvidar le
costaba trabajo olvidar las cosas
entonces el psicólogo lo estuvo tratando
y su rehabilitación consistió
paradójicamente en enseñarle a olvidar
resulta entonces que nuestra memoria
funciona muy bien como la tenemos
recordar más no es buena idea recordar
menos tampoco
vamos al segundo que tal poder cerrar
los oídos
muchas veces consideramos que la vista
es nuestro sistema principal para
percibir el mundo de hecho la mayor
parte de la corteza cerebral se dedica a
procesar información visual le gana a
cualquier otra modalidad de información
y sin embargo resulta que pasamos la
tercera parte de la vida con los ojos
cerrados
si vivimos 75 años consideren que más de
25 años habremos estado con los ojos
cerrados y sin embargo el oído s siempre
está encendido cuando se me ocurrió esto
de cerrar los ojos pues un día en el que
en la noche al vecino se le ocurrió con
la mejor de las intenciones claro
compartir su música
en ese momento pensé bueno porque no
puedo cerrar un rato los oídos pues no
es tan buena idea consideren que
prácticamente todos los animales que
están dotados de oído lo tienen siempre
encendido en este momento ustedes pueden
ver lo que está frente a ustedes si
voltean pueden ver lo que está detrás
pero no pueden ver más allá de las
paredes y sin embargo si pueden escuchar
lo que está más allá entonces el oído es
un excelente sistema para mantenernos
vigilando el entorno si hubo algún
animal que nació con la capacidad de
cerrar los oídos seguramente se lo
comieron por la noche entonces no es tan
buena idea lo de cerrar los oídos pero
el tercero poder predecir el futuro ese
creo que sí sería buena idea
bueno la buena y la mala noticia es que
a pesar de que es buena idea resulta que
ya lo tenemos la capacidad para predecir
el futuro a veces no le prestamos
atención porque es algo como muy
automático incluso nos parece como
risible algunas cosas por ejemplo si veo
el cielo y está nublado puedo predecir
parece sencillo pero consideren que a
nuestros antepasados por ejemplo las
señales que estaban en el entorno les
permitieron predecir ciclos de clima y
entonces se desarrolla la agricultura
entre otras cosas ustedes pensarán bueno
pues yo no veo como que puedo predecir
mucho el futuro pero hoy por la mañana
cuánto tiempo tardaron en levantarse o
más bien en decidir si se levantaban o
no
sé de buena fuente que algunos tardaron
más que otros eso supongo bueno a veces
parece una decisión automática pero no
lo es tanto más bien resulta que nuestro
cerebro en cierta medida y como un
superhéroe lo hace se imagina cientos o
miles de combinaciones que derivan de
levantarse y cientos o miles de
escenarios que derivan de no levantarse
los pone en una balanza y resulta que es
mejor idea levantarse que no levantarse
y en ese momento esas nos levantamos
porque porque sentimos que es mejor ir a
levantarse nos late levantarnos fue
automático no parece automático pero en
realidad depende de esta habilidad de
predecir que podría ocurrir este es un
poder que se puede desarrollar bastante
uno puede entrenarse en él y les voy a
dar dos ideas que les pueden servir una
puede ser cuando tomen una decisión no
sólo piensen en que ha ocurrido antes
cuando he tomado esta decisión por
ejemplo si ustedes se paran abajo de un
puente
y a las personas que cruzan corriendo
sorteando a los coches les preguntan
oigan por qué
y hace esto no le parece que es un poco
peligroso estoy seguro de que muchos les
van a decir es que lo he hecho antes y
nunca ha pasado nada bueno esa parece
una decisión mala de inicio no porque
entre otras cosas confía en que todos
los automovilistas se comportarán como
deben comportarse es decir que todos
irán poniendo atención y eso no lo
sabemos
entonces no piensen en que ha pasado
antes piensen también en qué es lo peor
que podría pasar y si puede pasar algo
muy malo y no sería raro entonces mejor
tomen otra decisión
de qué otra manera puedo tomar mejores
decisiones y predecir el mejor mejor el
futuro una puede ser nutrir mis
experiencias cómo hago esto pues
viviendo muchas cosas haciendo cosas
nuevas que no sabía hacer antes yendo a
lugares a los que no estoy acostumbrado
a ir así nutra mi experiencia para tomar
mejores decisiones pero hay una vía que
es un poco más rápida y algunos ya saben
cuál es esa es leer y leer mucho don
quijote el personaje de cervantes decía
el que lee mucho y anda mucho de mucho y
sabe mucho
uno puede beneficiarse de la experiencia
no solo de personas que vivieron hace
mucho tiempo y en otros lugares sino
también de la experiencia de personas
que ni siquiera han existido o personas
que vivieron o vivirán en el futuro
hipotético uno puede aprender muchas
cosas de los libros por ejemplo yo sé
que no es buena idea acercarse a un
agujero negro por lo tanto procuraré no
hacerlo
ustedes creen que será buena idea a
convertir las cosas en oro al tocarlas
creo que no y hasta donde yo esperaba
nadie lo ha probado pero alguna historia
nos enseñó que eso puede no ser tan
buena idea entonces leer mucho nos puede
ayudar a nutrirnos de las experiencias
para poder predecir el mejor mejor el
futuro y tomar mejores decisiones estás
gerons una buena idea poder predecir el
futuro
entonces la próxima vez que piensen
ustedes en superpoderes que les gustaría
tener consideren lo siguiente la
evolución a lo largo de cientos miles o
millones de años nos ha dejado muchas
cosas algunas son poco extrañas puede
ser por ejemplo la carne de gallina para
que nos sirve a nuestros antepasados les
sirvió para mantenerse calientes a
nosotros ya no nos sirve de gran cosa
ese es un súper bufón superpoder para
ellos para nosotros ya no pero esa
evolución también nos ha dejado entre
otras cosas esos ojos
de 100 megapíxeles con los que están
viendo esto muchas gracias
[Aplausos]